à dix mille kilomètres de la france sur
90 mille kilomètres carrés
voici la jungle guyanaise c'est là au
bord de la mer à 60 km au nord de
cayenne que le centre national d'études
spatiales a décidé d'implanter le centre
spatial guyanais champ de tir
entièrement civil pour les expériences
spatiales française pourquoi cet endroit
parce qu'il a une situation remarquable
tout près de l'équateur
grâce à l'appui donné par la rotondité
de la terre par la vitesse de rotation
de la terre on peut gagner 20 à 30% de
charges supplémentaires sur ordi en plus
liberté de tir total vers l'est
puisqu'il n'ya que l'océan atlantique et
d'autre part c'est une région calme
climatiquement à l'abri des tornades et
des ouragans
la décision de construction a été prise
en 1964 les débuts des travaux en 1966
voici pour la ville de kourou où nous en
sommes aujourd'hui
c'est maintenant une ville de plus de
3000 habitants dans deux ans elle en
aura dix mille c'est un véritable pari
[Musique]
un pari dont nous parle le directeur du
centre spatial guyanais
monsieur cramé consolera centre spatial
c'est à la portée de tout le monde si je
puis dire n'est ce pas on sait
exactement ce qu'il faut faire et par
contre ce que l'on ne sait pas parce
qu'on est dans un pays comme la cuillère
c'est ce qu'il coûtera d'une part et ce
que l'on ne savait pas exactement c'est
que l'on ce que l'on y rencontrerez
alors ce qu'on appelle un pari c'est
resté dans les limites de ce que l'on a
prévu au point de vue argent et dans le
délai l'on s'est fixés alors voilà ce
que voilà ce qui est vraiment notre pari
alors le résultat c'est que on reste
dans ce que l'on a prévu
et ceci sans aucune sans aucune
augmentation car notre direction est
très ferme dans cette affaire-là et dans
le délai on le respecte
dans les délais en effet le pari a été
respectée puisque mardi 9 avril quatre
heures de l'après midi cette vedette des
rentrées dans le port de cours ou sur le
pont arrière se trouvait la pointe d'une
fusée véronique lancé quelques heures
plus tôt pointe récupérer à 15km amer
dans d'excellentes conditions
m
tous les techniciens du centre spatial
guyanais et le directeur général du
centre national d'études spatiales le
général lotbinière tenait à assister à
ce retour lapointe était intacte
quoiqu'un peu brûlé par sa descente
ultra rapide dans l'espace puisque elle
était montée à 113 km d'altitude
la récupération s'était déroulée dans
d'excellentes conditions
moins d'une demi heure après le tir
lapointe été repéré dans la mer par un
avion spécial et deux heures après
prélevés par la vedette
[Musique]
mais revenons quelques heures plus tôt
sur l'air de lancement des fusées sont
voici véronique âge et 182e du nom avant
dernière de sa c 'est une fusée sonde
qui pèse une tonne 5 qui fonctionne à
l'essence de térébenthine et à l'acide
nitrique
elle mesure 8 mètres de haut sa pointe
technique mesure deux mètres cinquante
et peu mon créé à l'altitude de 150 km
quelques heures avant le tir sous une
pluie battante une pluie tropicale
le remplissage plume fine remplissage
des réservoirs s'effectue remplissage en
acide nitrique
des techniciens sont obligés de se
protéger par des combinaisons spéciales
et des masques à gaz
[Musique]
le remplissage en essence de
térébenthine s'est effectuée
l'après-midi dans l'après midi et s'est
correctement déroulée au pc de lancement
les techniciens aussi se prépare ici le
directeur du lancement monsieur k n
il vérifie que tout se déroule
normalement
les derniers contrôles s'effectuent ici
les tables traçantes qui vont inscrire
la trajectoire réel de la fusée suivi
sarah radars sur les routes de
rochambeau le piper navajo spéciale du
centre spatial guyanais se prépare c'est
lui qui avec des moyens radio
extrêmement puissant va être chargée de
repérer la poigne de la fusée il a à
bord en équipements radio une valeur
égale à celle du prix de l'avion
[Musique]
ultimes préparatifs sur la table de
lancement et dans le blockhaus de tenir
que voici les dernières vérifications
est en fait le compte à rebours va avoir
lieu
inconscient offre 9 8 7
5 4 3
2 à feu
départ moins rapide que pour une fusée à
poudre mais accélération après et
bientôt la fusée va passer à la
verticale de ce village de primitifs
saramaca situé à quelques kilomètres de
là mais évacué pour raisons de sécurité
tous les techniciens du centre spatial
guyanais et leurs directeurs peuvent
être heureux de ce tir
[Musique]
pour le directeur du centre ça
représente quand même une réalisation
que nous avons tous souhaité espérait
tous mes collaborateurs voire en ce jour
vire un virement très nette
jusqu'à maintenant une fusion
reconstruire parce que maintenant de
s'en retourner vers la réalisation et
chaque lancement sera pour eux
l'aboutissement de tous leurs efforts
voici donc courroux devenu enfin ville
spatiale
quels changements pour les premiers
constructeurs qui ne trouvèrent qu'un
village de 365 habitants et bien sûr pas
de victimes pas
[Musique]
voici le village initiale de kourou
grâce à une main d'oeuvre venus de tous
pays
le centre a pu être construit parmi les
travailleurs on compte vingt
nationalités mais surtout des
travailleurs d'amérique du sud dé guyane
et bien sûr des antillais mais aussi des
colombiens venu directement de leur pays
des brésiliens des vénézuéliens et
bientôt et voici ce qu'ils ont fait ici
les nouveaux logements verticaux les
appartements d'extrême qualité un hôtel
de 30 chambres bientôt un hôtel de 100
chambres et ici le restaurant le
dimanche près de 3000 personnes viennent
déjeuner ici et pour la guyane toute
cette réalisation est vraiment une
chance
[Musique]
évidemment que pour la guyane ne
représentant une chance je n'est ce pas
je ne vais pas dire lâchant jeudi qu'une
chance nous sommes implantés ici et nous
sommes une affaire qui est décidé à
réussir et qu'il réussira pour la
première fois en dix ans réussir à
quelque chose et on arrivera à faire à
faire oublier que la guyane est une
terre où il ya eu que des échecs et ça
je pense la guyane qu'il était grand
pour la guyane il était grand temps que
ça change
[Musique]